Hey, what's going on? Hey, baby.
It's the Monday morning podcast, um, for October 8th,
2017 what's going on? Uh, yes. I'm singing a little bit of Tom Petty.
Um,
I was lucky enough to be at the Florida gators game in the swamp against the LSU
Tigers and uh,
bam bam bam [inaudible] fucking SCC football,
80,000 people, whatever the fuck it is going. Absolutely ape shit. And uh,
they had this great tribute, which I'm sure some of you saw the clips, uh,
online of, uh, the whole stadium saying, I won't back down.
I was fucking on, you know, it sucks the guy died,
you know,
but he leaves all that great music and all that. What I want to, yeah,
that's a great fucking, that's a great life. You know what I mean?
Considering all this shit that fucking happens nowadays,
the fact that that guy was able to make it into his sixties,
the very least still sucks. He died, you know, but whatever, it was a great,
it was, it was fucking awesome. You know, it was hilarious as if you were there.
Everybody sang the shit out of that first first.
And then when the second verse came along,
you saw the radio fans and then the real Tom petty fence. Right?
Now everybody knew the first birds I, oh, Ella, whoa, Baghdad.
Noah stem, I don't know, the worst day.
And then all of a sudden the fucking everybody knew that
Yay
bare, right? And then it gets to the second verse, listen to it.
Everybody's just Kinda, well, ah,
everybody's just waiting.
Hey there.
Easy way out. Right? So, um, anyways,
we went to the swamp out there in a, in uh, Gainesville,
Georgia, where a Tom Petty is from. Evidently, I didn't know,
I didn't know that until he died. And, uh, I knew he was from Florida. Um,
yet another great musician from Florida, right? You get all the fucking,
all my brothers from down there, you got Tom Petty,
I don't know where the heartbreakers are from, but you know, I mean, he met him,
so they had to be somewhere near Florida, right?
Somewhere in the fucking lower 48. But, um, Jesus Christ did, uh,
did that stadium, Ben Hill fucking stadium, the,
this Aka the swamp. Did that thing ever live up to its fucking name? My God.
[inaudible]
we had upper deck seats and um,
it was a,
okay,
it was a, it was just fucking, it was ridiculous.
So we go up there and they had like the aluminum seats up top,
just like the old Patriot's stadium, you know,
and if you stood up during the winter time when everybody had the big winter
coats on,
if you stood up too long after a good play or most likely disappointing playback
, then when you went to sit back down,
you lost your seat and then you were just sort of standing up.
You couldn't sit down and then people would pelt you with hotdogs and fucking
snowballs and all that shit. And you know what you did,
you laughed and all your friends laughed at you. You didn't make a fucking,
you didn't have a cell phone to make a video and turn into a victim,
you know. So, um,
anyways, um,
we were sitting up there and you literally had to just walk back into the tunnel
and with all that heat coming off the field and all those people,
they're like literally when you walked into the stadium became like a wind
tunnel. So, and I was going out there, man,
and I'm going to tell you right now,
there was a bunch of people just fucking sit down all shapes and sizes,
all ages from kids all the way to old people just sitting down like, yell,
I got to take a good fucking 10 minute break here or I think I'm going to
fucking die. And then mercifully the sun started to go, by the way,
it's October, it's October, it felt like fucking August.
And um, the sun finally went down and, uh, it was a great game.
I know, you know, the gators were missing their a starting quarterback.
And I also know,
obviously LSU had that horrible fucking loss last week to the Trojans, Troy.
And um, so it was a big win for them. It was just a fucking,
it was a great game. Unfortunate that kid missed that field goal.
Everyone's chanting his name, Eddie. Eddie. You know,
I don't know what happened. The fucking kid missed the extra point.
Just kinda suck cause I would love to see an overtime. But uh,
there was this one LSU Fan, this old guy just, he was fucking hilarious.
Even like they get her fantasies, as annoying as he was,
he was just this old guy and he would do these stupid dances whenever LSU had
like a big play. He looked ridiculous.
It was making a complete ass of himself all the while having the best time of
his life and uh, in every way. I don't know.
It's just,
it's one of those just one of those great fucking moments why you go to sports
and all that shit. And uh, you know, we had a great time.
We didn't even pay for fucking parking either.
And then we found out why afterwards because we were so buried in. Um,
but uh, it was just awesome to finally go there. Legendary school,
legendary fucking field.
And I actually learned this about that field is that that field is what is in
like the top 20 biggest stadiums in the United States. Um,
here they are right here, Michigan number one, number two,
Penn state than Ohio state, Texas a and M, Tennessee. Uh,
LSU, Alabama, University of Texas,
USC, Georgia. That's the top 10.
Then UCLA, the cotton bowl, Nebraska,
Florida comes in at number 14, and I was pretty psyched as far as the top 10.
I've been to every fucking one of those stadiums except for Penn state.
And uh, let's see, other one, Michigan,
Texas and Tennessee. I haven't been in Tennessee,
so I gotta fucking knock those out. All right. I gotta try to do that Shit.
I know it's fucking stupid shit. But this is what this podcast is.
His podcasts is stupid shit. All right.
Stupid Shit that doesn't matter. And then listen to me,
you know, all these fucking assholes. You know,
I've been getting letters lately of really heavy variety. It's,
I don't fucking do that on here.
You're listening to the wrong fucking podcast is enough of that out there.
This place is to forget your fucking troubles.
Yeah,
fucking asshole. Some douchebag sent me this fucking email.
The name of the email is fuck America,
and then he goes on to present his argument about gun controlled psych buddy.
You started it off with Fuck America. Like w how would you,
how is the people that you want to listen to this going to listen to it after
that? So I won't be reading that one. You know what I mean?
At least fucking people screaming and fucking yelling about this, about that.
You know what I mean? Every time there's a big fucking tragedy.
You know what I love now? I love how everybody's got a fucking way in now.
Right? And then like it becomes,
my favorite things is celebrities react to the hurricane.
You know what I mean? Like, oh good.
I need to know what Jay Lo thinks about a category five. Oh, was she,
was she upset that that happened to Houston? Who wouldn't be?
Who Do fuck wouldn't be
okay.
I don't fucking item. I just don't understand why they do that.
I've never fucking understood.
Then there'll be like a fucking earthquake and then it's always like Hashtag uh,
fucking, uh, thinking about, you know, wherever the fucking earthquake hit.
You know, it's funny about those fucking accounts. Most of those,
like if you're smart, I guess you don't, you don't do your own account.
You have somebody else do it. So whenever anything bad happens,
they actually had somebody else doing it for the person so they don't get in
trouble. They don't say the wrong fucking thing. I just,
everything is just become that. I missed that whole story about Cam Newton.
He said some smart adequately thing to a fucking female reporter.
Right. And rather than her just settling with them, being like,
hey cam, why don't you go fuck yourself?
And then they laugh it off and they both drink a bud light or something.
A Miller light like that used to how it used to go down.
All of a sudden now he showed up to the game today for some reason dress like a
pimp, like a, I don't know what.
And then he's got like a fucking Rosie the riveter
I can think of that. He's going to say all these positive shit about women.
I don't, I just, I don't fucking, I don't know,
like it's just one fucking apology after another.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
the world is going to hell in a fucking hand basket and I got to fucking sit
here and, and I'm going to watch that. I need to see the resolution of that.
Like these two fucking adults cannot solve this amongst themselves.
I swear to God, I had was half listening to Cam Newton.
I swear to God he was talking to Rosie the riveter as if it was a real person.
Am I out of my mind or that wasn't that like a,
a like a caricature that represented women working in World War II?
Was it really a woman named Rosie and her middle name was the in the last name
was riveter. Um, I might be wrong, you know,
by all means.
Let me look this up before I have to have a press conference and fucking
apologize to somebody. Here we go. A A row
z the
the riveter. Rosie the riveter.
All right, Rosie. The river is a cultural icon. Yes.
I'd swear to God he was fucking talking like it was my Paula.
Maybe he wasn't. That'll be fucking hilarious. And lastly,
I'd like to apologize to Rosie the riveter. I know she did a lot of things. Uh,
she reverted a lot of rivets back, uh, down there by the river. And,
uh, I apologize.
Um,
here's something I wish people in the press could do.
I wish they could get their balls broken a little bit more,
especially if you got, if you kind of go in the locker room,
you know what I mean? If you're going to fucking go in there,
people are going to bust your chops like the athletes.
Like they should be able to sit there and be like,
what did you say you bald fat fuck,
who couldn't run 30 yards without having a heart attack?
What was your question about Mike? My decision in the second quarter.
Why can't they do that?
I don't understand why they can't do that.
Okay.
What'd you say lady?
Yeah.
Um, you address me as Ms Sports reporter.
I'll go fucking fuck yourself.
That stupid ass story is it?
We'll get more fucking coverage than pharmaceutical companies basically being
heroin dealers. You know what I mean?
They're not gonna fuck with that cause they advertise on that channel,
but God forbid somebody throws one high and tight at somebody with a fucking
clam and all of a sudden all js is the whole fucking world stops.
I'm not saying he shouldn't apologize. They should fucking handle it this thick.
He didn't say it to me. The fuck am I sitting there watching it for?
I don't know.
We lost like advertising money. I mean,
who can even fucking remember like what?
What do you know you only one thing I can ever remember,
this is some of the greatest advertising I guess because I can remember was
Shaquille O'Neal did it,
did a bunch of Buick ads and that was the funniest fucking thing ever because in
a lot of people, instantly when they saw it,
it's like Shaq doesn't drive a fucking Buick.
It's one of the top 50 NBA players of all time.
The fuck did he do with his money that he's driving a Buick? He would've,
he blew all his God damn from being a player.
We still got a TV gig. He's not driving a Buick.
You can't even fucking fit in one.
Maybe though that fucking Roadmaster for back in the 50s,
cut the roof off of Riviera. Maybe. I don't know. Take out the front seat.
He could sit in the back end. I Dunno.
Um,
actually Shaq is memorable.
I Dunno why he does that. And then he is the one with the little monopoly guy,
the general, which just looks like the cheesiest fucking insurance ever,
you know, and then check does that, you know, I'm not really smiling.
I'm just smiling because I'm going to get paid.
You know where he has the under and the overbite?
He just puts his top teeth on his bottom teeth.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about. I usually, like I said,
I usually don't fucking do these when I fly in the same day. I just,
of course I have no fucking time. I have a million fucking things to do.
Um, [inaudible] what else? What else? What else? Oh, should I address this?
I will address this,
the big fucking story that everybody's talking about out there.
I am of the firm fucking belief. I am of the firm fucking belief.
This is a new theory. I'm not saying I'm right,
but I am of the fucking belief that the fucking attention that they give to
these fucking lunatics is why more than ever people do that lunatic shit.
Okay?
Like do you remember when Kim Kardashians,
she made that sex tape and then all of a sudden somebody got ahold of it and
then it went out there and then it became like this porno tape and up until then
that was unbelievably embarrassing and it fucking ruined you.
And then that was it. That was fucking it.
But somehow she came out the other side with the TV show and is now like a
fucking again icon, multi fucking millionaire. And right after that happened,
what happened?
A bunch of women who wouldn't have done that shit went out and tried to do that
shit cause they saw it and what stopped it was none of it.
None of them fucking made it. However,
if they started fucking making it and started getting attention the way these
lunatics do, I saw on the cover of people magazine,
they let go and this is the deadliest, Yada, Yada, Yada. All fucking time.
You're given these, these fucking lunatics a number to now shoot for.
Wow.
Cause the same way I sat on TV and I sat at home and TV and I'm said,
oh look at that. Stand up. Stand up comedy. It looks cool.
I want to fucking do that. Lunatics want to do this other shit.
I am of affirm fucking belief. They should not fucking,
yeah.
Shouldn't say the dude's name.
That's it.
You go in, you whack the guy,
you throw him in a fucking incinerator and then you throw his ashes in a fucking
sewer. That's it.
Okay.
All right. And then you'd take care of whoever got fucking hurt.
That's what you do. All right.
But all this fucking shit that you then put it on the top and then you know,
one of these fucking channels they're going to,
they're going to begin to do like they do with the serial killers. You know,
you never know the victim's names.
You just know that those fucking people and all the fucking celebrities,
you know who, if they even run their goddamn accounts,
then they've got a fucking comment about it.
They'll celebrity reaction to the tragedy where they weren't at, you know,
something else. I fucking, I'm on a rant. You know what else I liked?
I liked all these douchebags who were taken videos of themselves.
They weren't anywhere near it. Hey, just letting everybody know that I'm right.
It's like, yeah, Dude, you're 20 fucking miles down the street.
Who the fuck even knew you were there? Who are you making this for?
You can't just text your friends and be like, yeah, dude, I'm cool.
I don't know.
Everything has got to be about, everybody's got to make it about themselves.
I fuck it. It drives me up. The fucking wall drives me up the fucking wall.
I have no solution for this shit, but I,
I do firmly fucking believe that they have to stop making these,
these fucking lunatics famous and ranking.
You know, the body count. Um, I, I might be wrong.
The fuck do I know I'm a comedian. Okay, I'll,
I'll apologize next week I'll wear a fucking, uh,
Ted Bundy button on a pimp hat and I'll fucking apologize to somebody. I guess.
I don't know what I'm all right. There you go. I'm done.
I'm done with my fucking rant there. Um, anyways,
what else? What else? So yes, I went to the fucking, uh,
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers game.
Um,
that just fine. That shit just drives me nuts.
It's not about so-and-so's fucking reactions,
but the people that were there and then the people came in and fucking helped
the people. It's not about the lunatic that did it. It's about those people.
That's what it's about. It's about you down the street.
Now he's fucking there and I fucking,
the DJ stopped playing records and I was like, well, what's going on?
Um,
anyways, I had a, I went to a,
I went to the fucking Buccaneers game, the pirate ship one,
not the Choo Choo train. It's very confusing for Boston sports fans. Okay.
We got one with a pirate ship, one with a Choo Choo train,
and our fans were fucking great.
Great Goddamn fans love the stadium and a, you know,
it's funny you could tell that they,
they built the pirate ship first and then they put the flat screen,
that giant screen afterwards because the Buccaneers won a super bowl,
I believe the 2002 season.
And I remember vaguely remember them.
They brought the flag up and they put it up on the ship, which was cool.
You know what I mean? That Buccaneers, their pirates or whatever,
they got the ship or whatever. Right. But now they got this giant flat screen,
so the fucking championship flag was blocking the TV screen.
So now their Superbowl flag is made out of Mesh and it's difficult to see.
It's like you want a Superbowl should be a giant fucking flag,
move the ship or fucking put the the championship flag somewhere else.
Maybe they have another one. I couldn't see it, but that struck me as funny.
You know what I mean? And it also made me like Tampa Bay. Well I'm just going,
look at these fleets, fuck gay only. They don't have a zillion dollars.
That just added onto this thing. Like somebody bought a house,
then they got a little money, they put a fucking addition on it, you know,
and somebody bought a boat, then a recession happened, you know,
then he came back to the good times.
He bought a big fucking TV and then they gotta adjust the sales.
You know, it's white.
You ever see like a degenerate gamblers sitting there playing cards you always
see like, like signs of when they want. They'll ever go really shiny bracelet,
you know, dirty hat, but like $500 sunglasses. It's just like,
it's up and down, up and down, up and down. Look the whole fucking wardrobe.
Okay.
Dirty jeans with like a fucking wearing a mink. Um,
anyways, so we went there, had a great time.
Was it barest by this one patriots fan who just would not sit down?
It was this fucking, you know,
this guy with like 140 pounds and he never got the shit kicked out of him
clearly. And he just wouldn't sit down and people argue, well this is right.
If he wants to stand up, it's like, but there's, you know, this is this guy.
He brought his girlfriend, she's short, she can't see around him.
There's nobody standing in front of them. And there's patriots. Fran was like,
you know, threatening to punch him in his forgot,
but I punch you right in your fucking ear.
It was really like patriots fans arguing with patriots fit.
It's fucking hilarious. And I saw that we even won the game.
We came out of the stadium and I saw there was a group of fucking patriots fans
and they were like arguing with each other and I just heard it vaguely or this
guy going to, why can't I wear a Teddy Bruschi Jersey if you can fuck away.
But then they just kind of walked by. Um,
yeah.
But anyways, it was a, uh, it was a great time and I,
we had a great show out there and then the next day,
all sober bill 53 fucking days in, uh,
we rode up to the swamp and uh,
listen to Ozzy on the way up because on the way up there, you kind of go, not,
you get like within like 10 miles.
I think if you take the 75 north of where Randy Rhoads died.
So we listened to some early Ozzy early, uh,
Solo Ozzie I should say on the way up. And uh,
just had a great time.
Pulled in fucking smoked a cigar at a great fucking time.
Got To go to another sec game. It was, it was a great time.
Definitely a great time. So thank you to everybody came out. I will definitely,
uh, definitely be back. I think the next time I come back,
maybe I'll go back for a Florida state. I've been to Miami,
I bet to a, I bet. Did a gator, so like, oh,
ain't left, really is Florida state. And then they sent one, like,
is it central Florida? There's another one that always has a lot of NFL players.
Is it southern Florida? Something like that. I can't remember. Whatever,
whatever. I'll figure it out. Um, oh that Patriot's fan wouldn't sit down.
He had a Tom Brady fucking jersey on in salmon shorts and everyone's going,
don't you sit down and shut the fuck down? First time somebody said, sit down.
And he goes, he turns around and goes, you would ask, we nicely, little shit,
little fucking guy. Um, and now like a stocky,
now I'll get tied. Domi built little guy. This was just a slight man and,
uh, I dunno, was taking sports way too seriously. I remember we, we,
we got a first down, like a big first down at the end of the game.
And he did like that. And you know, that,
remember that Jordan thing that he would do,
we'd make a fist and he fucking bring his arm up. You know,
when he sank the fucking shot and it was over, he fucking did that.
You know, when, when the Patriots got a first down,
he had fucking lower just sticking out and shit his ass.
I don't know what the fuck,
just looking at the Luna Tech and he just wouldn't sit down.
And finally Barnett got him to sit down. I can't tell you what he said.
I can tell you what it started with. He said, hey, Jyzelle
sit the fuck down. And I can't say the rest, cause everybody, you know,
everybody, everybody gets all fucking uptight now. Uh, but you know what?
It was effective.
He sat the fuck down and did not get up for the rest of the game.
And when he did,
he's a few times he got up on big plays and everything else got up and they sat
down. Then he was finally a fucking gentleman of up. Um,
here's an interesting question. Paul Versey asked me on the ride back, he goes,
do you believe in destiny?
Okay?
And I told him, no, he goes down, I'm just asking like,
do you believe like Michael Jordan was destined to be the greatest basketball?
And I was like, no, I don't. I don't.
And he was saying that he did that he believed that you, it's just, you,
you have your destiny and one of your destiny is like,
that's what the fuck your destiny is. And I just don't believe that.
I don't, you know what I mean?
I think you're born with the talent and if you work your fucking ass off,
you can make it happen. However,
how fucked up the world is,
there's a bunch of people that can take your destiny away from you. Like,
you could fucking have a, you know, your Destiny's to be whatever,
you're going to be a doctor and fucking Baba Baba.
And then you go out one day you drive down the street and you get hit and by a
drunk driver and you die. So like that was your,
that your destiny was to get hit by a drunk driver? I don't, I don't think that,
I don't think it is. I don't think it is.
I think if the world was a perfect place, everybody would reach their potential.
But, um, you know, I've said this before, like I,
the world doesn't give a shit about your dream whether it comes true or not.
It's fucking sucks.
And even if you make all the right choices and all that shit, you know,
some fucking lunatic can, uh, you know, take it away from you.
So, um, see this is why I don't talk about that shit.
All you conch asking me about it. I don't want to fucking talk its worlds
depressing enough as it is. Um, all right.
The all things comedy fucking festival, podcast read.
We're having our first all things comedy festival at the end of the month.
October 26th through the 29th in Phoenix, Arizona.
Okay.
I'm going to be there recording my first ever live Monday morning podcast.
I don't know how I'm going to do it. If I'm going to dress the crowd,
if I'm just going to come walking out, if I'll,
I don't know what I'm going to fucking,
no. Uh, Doug Stanhope the Great Doug Stanhope,
the legendary Doug staying up the, the national treasure
that is Doug Stanhope is doing his podcast at the Orpheum theater.
Uh,
Bert Kreischer [inaudible].
Jen Kirkman and the crab feast are also on the lineup.
Basically,
we've taken over downtown Phoenix with the pop up podcast studio and the whole
network is going to be there. If you're in the Phoenix area,
come hang out with us. Go to all things, comedy.com to get your tickets.
Um, I can't wait to do this, man. This is going to be fun as hell.
It's really going to be fun as hell. Uh,
I know this has been like a fucked up podcast cause I'm trying to talk around a
lot of shit and you know, and yet another one of my fucking friends died,
coworkers died and uh, it's just fucking fucking sucks.
It sucks. You know, Ralphie make the great,
Ralphie may unfortunately passed away this weekend and uh,
just legit, legit, legit fucking murderer.
That guy just fucking killed. He killed from the first time I saw,
I think it was, um,
was it the late nineties when he came out? I believe it was the late nineties.
He came out and there was already another comic there. Bigger guy,
Ron Lester, who also is since fucking passed away unfortunately,
which I didn't even realize he died last year.
So rested peace to him and um, you know,
those big guys had to deal with like clubs.
They kind of had this thing where they just, you know,
they had their big guy comic and uh,
so it was like weird. They almost were like in competition with each other. And,
um,
then Ron ended up getting all this acting work and he just sort of stopped doing
standup, but Ralphie came in and just was just a fucking,
was a force to be dealt with. And um, you know,
it just fucking sucks.
I remember you was telling me he was gonna teach me how to smoked meat or
whatever like that. You know, cause he was just going,
you don't know how to do it, Bill. He's like, he from fucking Massachusetts,
I'm from Tennessee, I'm going to show you how to do it, blah, blah, blah.
And of course we both got busy. We never got around to doing it.
And I know he's got two little kids, so, um,
I imagine someone's putting together benefit somewhere for it.
So I imagine I'll be doing that. But um, yeah,
it was just a fucking, just a fucking sad, sad time.
God dammit. Um, I remember I did the,
I the traveling virus tour with him. I did a lot of gigs with that guy.
Like a lot of those, uh, sort of, you know, I dunno,
he was much younger than me, but not much. I'm 49,
he was 45 we came up roughly,
he started younger than I did. That's what it was. Cause he,
we both kind of started at the same time, I want to say. So, um,
he was always as seasoned as I was.
So I always felt like I felt like we were the same age even though I was older
than he was. So as we went up, I just, a lot of comedy festivals,
a lot of tours, the tours always got better. He was the guy who told you this.
He was, Ralphie may was the fucking guy.
I remember I did this Gig Chu, she'll coot Charlie's, which is a great Gig,
but they fucking accommodations were,
was the worst accommodations I ever had was up in Alaska.
And I showed up and the bed literally was broken and it looked like,
it looked like the bed bugs like left.
Like they couldn't hack it. We're like, fuck this.
And I remember the boards were busted in the,
the mattress was like fucking attic giant,
creasing it and shit. And I was, you know,
raised Catholic or whatever. So rather than expressing that you didn't like it,
you just just took it and just was like, alright, I gotta be tough.
I gotta fucking,
I told you the first night is spent in fucking my walkthrough bedroom.
My first night in New York City, I felt this thing on my chest and I,
I turned on the light and there was a roach crawling across my chest and I
flicked it off my fucking chest. I didn't even kill it.
I just thought it was like, oh, this is what I gotta I gotta like a,
I gotta get myself tough enough to handle this.
Like I'm going to live with bugs crawling over me. Yeah,
I'm a fucking load a tech. I don't know what. So anyways,
so I do the Gig and I stay in that shit all.
So I end up going down to the laugh factory like a week or 10 days later.
And I walk in. Raffi was always hanging out, always did the work, you know,
and I came down and he was just like, hey bill, what's up? I say, hey man,
he goes way coming from, that's what we always asked each other. Um,
there was certain guys, you know, that were just road dogs. Hedberg Ralphie,
Stan Hope, Geraldo. Like these were, these were the guys.
Every time I went to a fucking club, um,
they either were just there or they were going to be there the next week.
I just, when I was coming up, we were all kind of close in the same rooms.
Like Hedberg was, I had a little bit ahead of me as was Stan hope. Um,
and those, but those,
they were roughly my age and those are guys that I really looked up to as far as
like, you know, they were just, they were like,
they started a few years before me, so they were just sort of cutting this
path. And they, and their style is like, I want to do that.
I want to say what the fuck I want to say on stay.
I don't want to do what they're doing. I want to, you know,
be who the fuck I am. The way they are was basically it. So anyways,
we used to always ask each other, where you coming from?
Where you going or whatever. Right. Whenever I ran to any of those guys. And um,
so I run into Ralphie and he goes, where are you coming from? I was like,
I did that Gig up in Alaska. Chilkoot Charlie's like, ah, fuck. I did that Gig.
Great Gig as like, yeah, great gig. And I was like,
Jesus Christ ago about that comedy Condo and Ralph,
we got this serious look on his face. He goes, he goes, I didn't stay there.
I go, what do you mean? He goes, man, he goes, I took one look at that place.
He goes, I'm not staying here.
And they got me a hotel room and I just looked at him and I said,
you could do that. And he laughed. He goes, yeah. He goes,
what the fuck they got to do? He goes, it's Alaska.
They're gonna get another fucking comedian to fly six hours all the way up
there, have some lumberjack, go on stage and tell some street jokes. It's like,
just, just say no. And, uh, that was one of those things I,
I fucking learned that. I was just like, all right. And after that, after that,
if I went someplace, I just, and it was a shit. All I just said no.
And if they just said, we're not paying for a hotel room, I said, you know what?
I'm gonna, I'm gonna pay for a fucking hotel room.
And it was worth it to just be able to go back to a fucking place where you felt
safe and you didn't feel like there was going to be bugs crawling on you or
somebody just all over the fucking bar.
God knows what fucked some chicken or period.
Not even going to tell you that fucking story of a comedian knows that.
Fucking want their God damn fucking crime scene cleaning lady quit.
The big rumor was the bloodstains was still on the fucking window.
Self swear to God. This is all, this is all, this is not myths.
I'm
so God dammit. Ralphy I'm gonna mess your buddy.
Uh, fuck. Anyways. All right. Let's get into some,
now that I talked about another dead friend. Let's talk about,
let's talk about some advertising here. Uh,
Luke crate everybody, give me, uh,
Luke crate be the envy of your friends and get your 100% exclusive
crates@lukecrate.com slash burr and enter my code bird to save $3 off on any new
subscription. October.
October's Luke crepe theme is mythical m I.
S I cannot believe these people are still advertising me.
This can only mean one thing that you guys are end this shit.
Can somebody please write into the podcast
and explained to me what this is.
I just pictured this is a giant trunk of light sabers and under reus,
uh,
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
Monthly wearables and accessories with coke classics and your favorite and your
favorite franchises. Franchise to me is McDonald's.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with the n with even bigger loot with Lou crate DX.
Want to geek out your pet. Try loot pets.
Offer expires night, October 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
You hear this stories, the whispers of creatures and beings beyond imaginations.
Now I don't, I don't even know what you're talking about. You hear the stories,
the whispers of creatures and beings beyond imagination.
Is that like a Joel Olsteen quote?
You hear the stories, the whispers.
God wants you to have creatures and beings beyond, beyond imagination.
Join us as we peer into the shadows.
Oh Jesus fucking creeps or look into the other realms for October's truly
mythical collection. Get unreal items from marvel, Ghostbusters,
stranger things and Buffy the vampire slayer. All right, I know it.
All of those things are a one lucky subscriber will also,
when a mega crate of seriously epic proportions you have until the 19th at nine
p. What the, what the fuck do you get in it?
Stranger things like Jojo or some shit, I don't know.
Just subscribers wherever that let you guys know what it is cause they keep
advertising and received that month's crate and when the cutoff happens,
that's it. It's over. Go Lou.
crate.com/burn edge my code Berbee you are already saved $3 off on any new
subscription today.
Okay?
She got a trunk full of stuff abundantly every fucking month.
Uh,
is it a nice trunk that you get to keep it or is it disposable dollar shave
club? Everybody, buddy. Uh,
everyone knows dollar shave club ship's amazing raises for a few bucks at this
tool. There are too many options and you can,
you can't tell the difference between any of them.
Then if you have any questions,
the clerk usually doesn't know the difference or there's only one person working
in the store. It becomes a major pain in the ass.
You've got to wait 20 minutes for someone to find the key. Right?
Dollar Shave club makes it easy and convenient for you to upgrade your shave and
your bathroom.
Now you don't have to to set foot in a store to get high quality shape and grow
me products.
Dollar Shave Club delivers them right to your door just like their raises.
Everything is super high quality and will leave you looking and feeling amazing
for only $5. This start a set features there.
Executive Razor and trial size of their most popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean.
And your first box you receive their shave butter body wash in one wipe
shyly bought wipes. You'll also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium weighty handle and full cassette of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges are sent for only a few dollars a
month.
This offers exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burger that's dollar
shave club.com/bar dollar shave clubs.
High quality products will have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the club. All right. Oh look who's here.
So
Zip
[inaudible].
What if hiring could be easy, more streamline and less time consuming?
So even when you're busy,
you could still be smart about the way you hire with ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to over 100 of the Web's leading job boards with just one
click.
So you can rest easy knowing your job is being seen by the right candidates.
Then Zip,
okay.
Ah, puts it at smart matching technology to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes of posting so you receive the best
possible matches. It's like a dating site,
except you're hiring people to work at your company and not to suck you.
You can even get a head start on the interview process by adding screening
questions to your job posts to help identify the most qualified candidates so
you don't have to waste time sorting through a stack of resumes to find the
perfect fit. No wonder 80% of employers who post on Zip,
okay.
[inaudible] get on quality candidates through the site and just one day and the
easy to use zip.
Okay.
Dashboard lets you manage your height, met you,
manage your hiring process from start to finish, all in one place.
This smartest way to smartest way to hire.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find the most qualified job candidates with the media results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free.
That's right for free. Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burger one more time. Hi,
that zip,
[inaudible] dot com slash Barb. All right, the last one, everybody.
It's helix. Helux uh,
you know there are a ton of online mat mattress retailers popping up these days.
Are there? I have no idea.
All with a one size fits all solution to a better sleep. Guess what?
One size fits all doesn't work.
Helix sleep offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalize to your unique preferences and sleeping styles that won't
set you back. Thousands of dollars. Go to Heloc, sleep.com/burr.
Take those simple two to three minutes. Sleep quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress.
That would be the best thing you've ever slept on for couples.
You know what I would love?
I would love a mattress that when I fall asleep with a glass of booze in my
hand, it doesn't spill on my pajamas.
But that's the old me and I gotta be honest with you.
I miss the old me and I'll tell you right now,
I would be as great as I feel not drinking for the last 53 days.
I'll tell you right now, all freckles is getting thirsty, um, for,
for couples, they even personalize each side of the mattress.
Butterflies for her big old titties. For you,
everyone from GQ Mazda's magazine to cosmopolitan to the New York Times are all
talking about what you pay for advertising. I'm talking about he looks,
and once you try it out, you'll know why your cuss,
your custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week and shipping is
completely free. Try it for 100 nights. If you don't love it,
if you don't love that mother fucking mattress, God damn and we'll come back.
They'll pick it up, gross and refund you in full.
I always pictured them showing up in like fucking the Walter White Hazmat suit.
[inaudible] pop and Margaret Country Shrimp. Go to helix,
sleep.com/bar right now and you'll get $50 towards your customer metrics.
That's helic sleep.com/ [inaudible] for $50 off your order.
He sleep.com/ [inaudible] all right,
let's go to the questions for the week yet that Duh, dude, dude, dude, dude.
All right. Fuck you. America. I'm not reading that one. Um,
our, my mom and her boyfriend being selfish or am I,
uh, by the way, the person who will fuck you. America. I'm not saying that you,
that you didn't make some decent points there,
but it's a waste of time for you to write that for me to read it after you write
that. All right,
why don't you grow the fuck up and come up with a more mature title?
And I'll read that one. How about that? How about that? How about that?
And then I'll wade into the topic of gun control is if I know a fucking thing
about it or even have a solution, our, my mom and her boyfriend being selfish,
or am I dear bill,
I'm 19 and live at home working to get this carpenter's apprenticeship with the
local union. And please don't say my name on the podcast. Well,
why would you give me your name? You fucking moron. Um,
about two months ago,
my mom's boyfriend started coming over and staying over to a point where he was
practically living their gross. Uh,
they would stay here and this place,
they would stay here in his place. Exactly half the time.
The first three days he was here, I heard there headboard day and night.
I was like, who the fuck is this guy? Oh my God,
boy. Oh boy. My mom said they had been friends for a year now,
but only went on two dates.
I asked her to have them not be here as much and if she could just come home
without him. I don't want him.
I don't want to talk to my mom with this guy right fucking there. Uh,
nothing changed until one night I snapped in one on a rampage.
My mom called the cops on me that night and now the half the time they would,
they would have spent here is just my mom now. But here's the kicker.
So that's good. You've got 'em out of the house. But here's the kicker.
Two weeks later he proposed, oh boy.
When my mom talked to me about it,
she asked if I had a problem with her wearing the ring. Literally,
the question was only about the ring, not the engagement.
I feel totally disrespected by him and my mom for not seeing that this guy has
no respect for her son.
I've decided to join the coast guard because the union stuff is taking too long.
I would have just moved in with my dad if every day he didn't just bring out how
much of a bitch my mom is. Jesus Christ. Dude, this is awful, man.
I'm sorry you're going through this and I was,
life sucks and it can't and I can't be around that. Uh,
I'm ready to walk away and just dropped my family entirely, entirely.
My Mom's swears this guy's a super, super nice,
but he doesn't give a fuck about her life as a mother and subsequently me.
Or maybe I'm wrong.
I just wanted to get another opinion because I'm ready to just cut off everyone
in my family and walk away. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Well,
it's your mom and your dad. You don't want to do that. Um, you know,
I could see why you want to get out of the house.
When gave somebody bang your fucking mother. I mean, Jesus Christ a mom.
How about doggy staff? You know what I mean?
You always got to be in the fucking missionary position. Um, something for,
for Christ's sake. And you slide down the bed a little more. Um,
alright. Well until you move out,
I would recommend getting some wireless headphones.
Maybe those Bose ones that block out the fucking noise.
I don't know what to tell you dude. Um,
I wouldn't join the coast guard unless you wanted to. Uh,
or the coast guard sounds. That sounds like a great fucking job to me.
Although I did fucking talk about, you know,
that time I went on that thing about like whenever a fucking hurricanes come in
on everybody's, you know, going to safety,
like how everybody in the coast guard is just like,
and they got to be on pins and needles cause they know some dumb fucks going to
take this stupid boat out there and then when they fuck up and then they call to
rescue them, these poor men.
And women are going to have to go out and go fish them out. Um,
all right. So what are you asking me here?
I would not cut out your mother and your father. Uh, I would tell,
I would communicate to your mother how you feel about that guy and now you don't
feel that he respects you. Okay. And that's the reason you're leaving, I guess.
And then I would talk to you dad saying, you know, dad,
I would love to stay with you,
but all you do is bitch and say what a bitch my mother is.
And she's my mom and I am sick of listening to it. All right?
Just try to say it in a nicer fucking way. But um, I
don't, it doesn't sound like they're hearing you. Ah Fuck.
But here's the thing, dude, if you're going to be, you can't,
you gotta fucking clear the air with them because you can't go into the coast
guard in angry fucking lunatic.
Cause what's going to happen is you're going to get into a fight or something
cause you pissed off at that fucking Douche who's banging your mom.
And then that's going to affect your career. So, uh,
this is something that I've been working on. This is fucking brutal. Uh,
forgiving people
like that guy you got to somewhere in your head and just forgive the guy for
being a fucking moron and see, get that off of you.
And, uh, you know, when you forgive somebody, it does,
it does a lot for you. It gets it off for you.
And then what you should be focusing on is trying
to figure out what your dream is and start walking towards it every day and uh,
and creating a life
that isn't like what you grew up with so your kid someday doesn't have to
fucking deal with what you dealt with. And, uh, you know,
and that doesn't happen overnight.
And the mistakes I made was I went out thinking, all right, I wanna,
I wanna change all this about what I didn't like about growing up.
But then what happens is you grew up,
you gravitate towards what's familiar and you end up re,
I think he kinda go out and recreate it. Um, inevitably.
And then you have to dismantle that start over again.
At least that's what happened to me.
I'm up super imposed and whatever the fuck happened to me. But uh,
uh, I wouldn't come at your mother or your are or your dad with anger.
I would just say, listen, I, uh, I, I forgive you.
I forgive you. I'm not happy with this. I forgive you.
I understand you gotta try, try to do what's right for you.
But this bothered me because x, y, and Z. And just say, tell you that's a dad.
You know, some, I gotta forgive you for something and they'll get his attention.
I forgive you for every time that I came over here and you went on and on about
what a fucking bitch my mother was alright at,
did a lot of damage and it did so much damage that I have to sit here and try to
figure out how to forgive you for that.
And then just stop talking to him and listen to what he says. Okay.
If he's any sort of a man,
his head's going to drop and he's going to fucking apologize to you.
And you can, you know, and I'm not saying that at all.
The anger you're going to have towards them goes away. Right. Then it,
you start that.
And if you guys work on starting over from that point and really fucking work on
it and really fucking communicate, uh,
hopefully you can go out into the world and not be an angry young man like I was
because I heard a lot of people. Um, all right. There you go. All right,
problem with girlfriend. Dear billion.
I have a big problem with my girlfriend, with my [inaudible]
Lady [inaudible]
James, call me Toby. I
have a big problem with my girlfriend. Um, if we've been date, we are,
we've been dating for the past three years and I think I might want to marry
her. Uh,
but for the last month or so we've been having a fight.
My sister and I are very close and since my parents died last year in a car
crash, we moved in together, which for some reason pissed her off.
I don't know why. Well, I mean, where were you living before that?
She probably half to three years. Wanted you to move in with her?
Probably once a God damn ring. Um,
then for some reason the fact that my sister and my best friend still smoked pot
and that they are doing it. Then for some reason,
the fact that my sister and my best friend still smoked pot and that they are
dating as well. Oh, she doesn't like that either. Um,
I would admit it was weird for me at first, but I got used to it anyway.
The fight was about the fact that she wants to move in,
that she wants me to move in with her. Yeah. Obviously,
but I don't want to and she refuses to move in with me as long as my sister is
there. I do love her and all that stuff.
But this is something that I just can't do.
My sister is in a very fragile place right now and my girlfriend can't get that
or won't, I don't know what to do if possible. Can you ask me?
I feel like women would understand better. Well,
she's downstairs dealing with my daughter. Um,
here's the deal with women. They're, they,
they work on a different clock than we do. All right?
So you just took three years of her life. All right.
And all she's hearing is, you know, you know that story,
that telltale heart under the floorboards, that's their,
that's their fucking womb. All right?
They have a finite amount of time where they can have kids all right,
before you stay, have to start doing some buck Rogers shit. Okay.
And women do not want to go through that if they don't have to. All right?
So what she needs out of you is some sort of fucking commitment. All right.
And she was looking for that after three years.
The fact that all she wanted to do was move in, she's being pretty cool.
She should probably be going for the fucking ring depending on how old you are.
Um, and what I would do with, if I was you, dude,
I would man the fuck up and either the commitment to her,
I break up with one or the other.
Um,
although the wildcard is,
is that your parents died last year in a car crash, so
you're probably not in a place emotionally to make that fucking decision.
Um,
yeah. Jesus Christ. You know what? Fuck everything that I just said.
Your parents died in a fucking car crash last year.
You got to look out for your family members and if she can't fucking understand
that, then uh, I didn't know. I Dunno what to tell you.
I guess she got to figure out how many you're going to find out how much you
love her. You know,
if she got to let it go, maybe you've got to let it go. I don't know.
I have no fucking idea. Um,
but I understand her side.
I've invested three years in this and you moved in with another woman and it's
your sister. That seems like a step backwards to her.
And then she has to move in. She wanted to fucking,
she lets this chick wants to marry you.
So she wanted to move in and then have you guys have a bunch of communal stuff
because women think that if you do that, that you're not going to get end.
There's a less of a chance that you're going to break up with them.
They feel like it's moving in a positive direction and you went left,
took a left hand turn, but life gave you a fucking lefthand turn.
So you're both not wrong. Why don't you try that?
Just say to her, look, you're not wrong for being mad at me
and I'm also not wrong for taking care of my sister.
And then just stare at her and whoever talks first loses
something along those lines. You're not wrong. And she's not wrong.
She's not wrong at the three years to fucking be like, what the fuck?
And you're not wrong for looking out for your sister when something tragic like
that. This is fucking nothing but tragedy nowadays.
Jesus Christ. Sorry that happens for you sir. Uh, two year, sir. Alright.
Geographically locked by marriage. Jesus. There's just,
there's just no real light here. Uh, Hi Bill. Love your work.
Thank you for the laughter. Hey, something positive.
I've been in a relationship since 2011 with a European woman that became a
marriage. I am originally from South America,
educated in the u s went to fancy school there. MIT. Look at you. You smart.
Best then got my phd in Europe. Whoa. Lottie da.
Spread your brain all around the fucking world, dear. Uh,
we've been a solid couple.
Our glue was out of love from mountaineering mountain climb.
Is that what did it mountaineering? I didn't know what the fuck that is.
There's some weird section or does that mean you? You fucking,
it's not rock climbing mountaineering.
You just walk up a mountain yodeling and outdoors sports.
Fuck is mountaineering.
Jeep had a wagon here. I remember that. I remember a mountain here
mount to nearing Wikipedia.
You always have the answers. The term mountaineering describes the port,
the sport of mountain climbing.
Also rock climbing is what people do at gyms now in mountaineering is if you
actually go up a mountain, okay, I get it.
While some scholars identify mountaineering related activities as climbing
parentheses, rock and ice and trekking up mountains.
Others are also adding backpacking, hiking, skiing.
Oh, Jesus Christ. I already see these groups where we're mountaineering too.
We just take a ski lift. All right, mountaineering. All right.
Jesus Christ. Dude, what are you fucking James Bond.
Born in Africa and went to MIT. Got Your Phd in Europe.
Your fucking client. You climb mountains. Other outdoor sports.
What are your top mountain? Airings.
Huh? What do you do from,
I'm trying to think how you topped it as far as outdoor sports,
but now things are,
yeah.
What else do you do?
You grab cobras by the fucking tail and kiss them on the back of their head.
By now things are a bit sour. What happened? We are way, way,
we'd always been a solid cup or our glue was out.
Our love for mountaineering outdoor sports, but now things are a bit sour.
I don't see how I can have a career here in this continent and she's a working
class lady who would suffer a lot from moving.
I also have a good business possibility in my home country. Brazil.
Oh, South America. I thought you said Africa. South America.
Okay. So you simply can't let that go.
I developed some somewhat of a scorn for the paperwork required to simply exit
exist in Europe and would rather be on my own, live up to my own country,
uh,
make my money and have the freedom to explore my vast underdeveloped continent,
but she wouldn't be able to come along. Also for my high tech education,
most good jobs are in the great us of a,
but I'm also burnt out with visas and permits and red flags. Uh,
I don't think I have the strength to beg for a high tech job that will pay me
less than my business in Brazil. Other than that, we get along fine.
She's a solid partner, but not the type who would survive the third world.
I think it's a no brainer, but I'm lost homebound and we'd love your thoughts.
Thank you. Ah, Jesus Day. I mean too,
that's a huge figure that you're gonna ask a fucking comedian who doesn't know
you to make that decision.
Um,
I think at the end of the day, whenever it comes down to stuff like this,
you have to make decisions that are going to make you happy,
all right? If
you don't, you're not going to be happy.
And then you're going to make the person you with miserable. However,
if there's kids involved, then you know,
you gotta man up and suffer. It doesn't sound like you've got any fucking kids.
All right? If you're married to this woman and you don't have any fucking kids,
then you know,
if you're going to start getting resentful and you're just going to argue and
argue and argue and argue,
all you guys are gonna do is take great years,
young, healthy, fucking years of your life.
We should be having a good time and you're gonna just make each other fucking
miserable. All right? So either you figure how to fuck, just stay with
her or she comes along with you or you go your separate ways. But
um,
if you need to, you know,
cause guys were not good sometimes expressing ourselves.
Maybe just sit down before you talk to her.
You write down what would make you happy?
You write down the points you want to make. I used to do this shit. Sorry.
I can, I still haven't mastered this,
but so I could figure out how to fucking have a productive confrontation and I
would list all the points that I wanted to make.
I would list what I wanted and then I would draw a big stupid smiley face
reminding me not to be an angry cunt. Um, so I don't know if that helps you.
I hope it did.
Um,
so anyways,
as if there weren't enough tragedies this month, my fucking,
my fucking, uh, I don't what happened, they didn't record the f one race today,
so I missed that. Japan one. I did see the clip where for whatever reason, uh,
Lewis Hamilton and Sebastian Vettel were like in some meeting in front of all
the other drivers, like telling on each other, you know, oh,
he took his steering wheel off. You know, the guys I go,
we took his seat pell, all those loose. It just made me,
I just slide it just, I swear to God, man,
I is like f one is that like the soccer of of motor sports.
I can't, but we would kind of have a fucking, I don't understand people who,
they have the balls to drive 200 miles an hour on each other's fucking bumpers,
staring death in the face and then they go in there and they fucking telling on
each other. I just, that was really disappointing to see.
Um,
I still love the sport. It's such a great fucking sport, but I don't know,
you know what it is. Maybe it's just, maybe that's just, it's too much access.
I don't need to see that shit. You know what I mean? I don't need to see that.
Fuck. I don't need to know all the fucking ins and outs.
The Rosie the riveter is this guy fucking complain about this or that.
But anyways, come back. Congratulations to Lewis Hamilton.
Despite the fact you're telling on people in meetings shamelessly.
Maybe that's like a fucking European thing.
Like they just have different fucking rules over there. You know what I mean?
You can walk around in a banana hammock fucking speedo and that's just totally
acceptable fucking telling on people. I mean that was just,
that was embarrassing.
Um,
I dunno, I don't fucking know why did I bring up how much I love boozing though.
I'm just thinking about getting one of those custom mattresses.
Remember that thing where they used to have the lady jumping up and down on the
mattress and the guy would have the glass of red wine and it wouldn't spill.
That's what I need. Uh, anyways, I start, uh,
I got some acting work coming up here over the next, uh, I don't know,
four or five weeks. So I got in at least another 20 days on whole,
not booze and thing. And um, I'm actually really enjoying it.
I've dropped some weight and shit. I, I do enjoy not drinking,
but I will tell you this,
it's just nighttime right now and it's fucking difficult. Oh, look who's here.
Hey Baby. There ain't no easy way. Yeah,
I won't back down. You know,
I was one of the great things I've ever seen in this sporting event.
Great. Can you please say that again? Do your impression of me again
or a seen at a sporting event.
The lovely Nia. Everybody. Okay, dad,
how are you doing? Oh, I'm doing good. I'm doing, I'm great. Baby's asleep.
Oh God. What's going on? It's been a while. Yeah,
I got her all amped up today, didn't I? Yes you did.
She had one nap for 30 minutes all day. That's ridiculous.
Well, weeks. We were excited to see each other.
Yeah, she was excited to see you. It was cute. Guys are cute.
I, it's ridiculous. I love that kid obviously. Um, Ooh.
What do we got here? Oh, I already read this one. Oh, this guy won. All right.
I, I'll just paraphrase these two things, right? Oh, you already did them.
You don't have to go back. Well, there was one guy, right?
Is his, his mom. He's like 19.
He lives at home and his mom has a new boyfriend and he could literally hear the
headboard getting fucked. Yeah. Terrible. Terrible, right? Yeah.
And then if you go eat, go stay with his dad.
But his dad is always talking about what a bitch is. You know a divorce. Oh,
that's photo X. Yeah.
So now he's thinking of just like joining the fucking coast guard,
just so he didn't know. Well, I mean if you want to,
but that seems like an awfully extreme. What'd she get a job at?
Like child world? Maybe you should. Yeah, definitely try to find his own place.
Try to stay on land and working out. Yeah, I think so.
I don't think that you'd have to join nothing.
There's anything wrong with the coast guard. I think the coast guard,
you gotta it's gotta be rain and posy scattered me. How you kill?
You walk around a uniform. You're on a boat. You can vent. You have other dudes.
Yeah. Then you, but you're not like, you're not out to see us anytime.
Oh, does it? Does it not count if you're on a boat? What do you mean?
That's just what not count. I don't know what you're saying. I mean,
you know. Oh, right. You know what I'm thinking? I'm thinking of the navy.
The coast guard is not the same as the navy. No, it isn't. What do you, what?
What are you, when you said, when you said it doesn't count, what do you,
what do you mean what doesn't count?
Like you know like when guys go to jail and stuff, like it doesn't count.
Like you're not like necessarily you're talking about guys banging other guys.
How did you get dead? No. And what does it mean that doesn't count
to see whoever said where. Did you ever hear that?
I feel like you have a bang a guy. Yeah. It didn't count. I was out on a lake.
No,
I feel like for sexually flexible men or whatever,
like if you're in an extreme situation like jail or out to sea in God's name,
are you talking about like it doesn't, nothing. These people that go out,
somebody tips over and an inner tube, there's a drug dealer coming up.
They go out and they fuck them up and then they come back. Yeah,
they go on a patrol. But this isn't like, no, no, no. I got confused. I was,
I was thinking man, it was like the navy. Why aren't you like out on a boat?
Like for months? Yeah, but the navy then out there fucking each other.
They come into port and then they bang a bunch of, I was,
there's in the navy you can help your fellow man.
That was the village people. All right. Do you think native Americans are gay?
Cause I, one guy with the head dress was going macho, macho man,
but they were singing about like guys stuff like places where there's groups of
men together. Listen, I've been to the YMC A, I never fucked another guy.
I went there and I used their unbelievably old workout equipment.
I played some pickup. Hope I didn't see any gay sex happening there.
All right, well fine. Obviously the coast guard is not as aim as the navy,
but I was just saying that if it was,
it would be fine because it doesn't count because you're out to sea and like you
just your normal element and it's like,
are you like high right now? I swear to God I'm not.
I know I sound really high right now, but I'm not,
but like you can, she's getting over being sick. By the way.
This isn't like some smoker thing with her. Um, yeah.
Cause they're going to be like, oh, she's got a smoker's cough. Um, no, I just,
uh, I dunno, my point is I don't know what my point was. I was saying, you know,
my thing is the navy. No, I feel like, oh, he's doing in the coast guard.
He's joined the coast guard. I figured that's, that's like a fucking a,
like if you meet someone in a bar would think as a woman's guy said he's in the
coast guard. It's like being like, you know, women like fireman.
It's like you're a fireman except you're fucking on a boat. Yeah. No,
that's fine. Yeah. And you're like going in. There you go. Yeah. It's hot.
There you, that's what, that's what I was talking about.
You have to go and talk about jail sex.
I don't want to fuck that came from isn't enough. This kid has to think of,
we hear his mother getting banged up against the fucking headboard.
You've got to bring up fucking prison sex.
You know, this podcast has taken a lot of left turns throughout the years.
That was one of the bigger ones. All right,
well you don't have to join the coast guard just to get away from your,
but maybe you do. I don't know. What does the Coast Guard do?
They're like the cops of the water. Right? Okay.
This is who I married.
Everybody is when you thought she was the brains of the outfit.
We have a child that we're going to raise. What is the coast guard? Oh wait,
that's right. Um, aren't they like the cops of the water?
Hey, did they get upset when there's like a tornado and a tornado? Look,
I've dealt my aim. A fucking hurricane. Hey, settled down water.
That'll be enough of that. No, they actually do a lot of bad ass shit.
But people, they save people's lives.
They fly out there and fight all these fucking dopes.
But they are the cops of the water. I mean,
they would be insulted to hear me saying that.
A nicer way to say is they guard the shores of this great country. Can they, oh,
that's nice. Can they arrest? Oh God.
So like fucking that guy from a male. Yeah. Oh, good for you.
Um, can they arrest you? The coast guard? Yes.
I would love to see you with a giant shipment of drugs when they pulled up.
Who are you guys? Do you guys like have sex with each other?
Oh, you're the coast. I'll wait. You're like the cops of the water.
Wait, can you arrest me?
I would pay a fucking me all the money in the world just to see the look on
their fucking face. I know. I'm insulting.
So many coast guard members, officers,
well officers, no, there's all different ranks.
I imagine this, there's semen.
Keep your mind out of the gutter all the way up to officers is captains.
[inaudible] you want me? Hey, why don't we do this? You know, Nia, when, when?
When? I don't know stuff.
I just asked the Internet and whoever made a page on it, then I just go, oh,
that's what it is. That's what it is. Okay.
The coast guard.
Let's get it. Let's get a,
I gotta go Wiki on this so they'll actually help me out here. All right.
Okay. The United States Coast Guard is a service,
a chief and highest ranking member. Oh, this is the commandant of the coat.
United States Coast Guard. Sorry.
Your phone is vibrating over the United States.
Coast Guard is a branch of the United States armed forces and one of the
countries. Yeah,
you, you, you, you can't save everything by saying the water.
Nia, you've been watching the Kardashians show way too fucking much here.
All right to mean Jesus. All right, one second.
The coast guard is a maritime military multi-mission service unique among the u
s military branches for having maritime law enforcement.
Can they arrest people with jurisdiction in both domestic and international
waters? Now there is a big one I didn't know international,
so you can't like outrun these fuckers and then just sit there and make faces at
them the second you get out in international waters.
I didn't know that they had a federal regular.
I thought once you went out and entered a international waters, it was captains,
captains, la, right. Captain's log, uh,
in a federal regulation emission is part of the mission. It's mission set.
It operates out of the US Department of Homeland Security during peace time and
can be transferred to the u s department of the Navy. But
alright, I'm going to stop. No, no, see. Right. So I,
I didn't realize that they would then activated.
I thought they would like the f like sort of the farm team,
like AAA of the navy. Oh, the water of the water. Yes.
You know,
there's a lot of people laughing at us right now and they didn't know that they
could be activated to the navy. Um, all right.
My point is, I was just saying this has happened twice,
that they made part of the navy once in 1917 during world war one and another
time during World War II. And that's obviously, you know,
Pearl Harbor happened and the German u boats and I dunno what the fuck happened
in World War One. Okay. Where there wooden ships off our coast,
right? No, they weren't. Wouldn't ships at that point,
although the fucking biplanes were made out of like Kleenex I think. All right.
I think that we've showed how dumb we are.
[inaudible] I'm all right. That's the podcast. Everybody,
if you'd like to see this live,
if you'd actually like to see this train wreck live. Once again, all things,
comedy festival, podcast, uh, all things.
Oh what is this all things? Comedy Festival. Uh, we are having this uh,
on October, 2026 to the 29th in Phoenix, Arizona.
I'm going to be at stand up live on October 28th doing this podcast. Live,
live, live. And it's been a lot of people requesting that you're there.
Really the, we got the Kiddo so I dunno if that happens.
I don't know about that. Where is it? It's an Arizona.
You want to fly to Arizona to do a podcast for free.
Hey, how funny was it the other day?
The other day when you were getting sad and you were starting to cry and I just
kept making that sad face,
which would then make you laugh and then you couldn't cry.
I hate when Nia cries cause I don't know what to do. I told you that story.
Big Tears. Big Tears. Right. So she was talking,
I didn't know what the fuck she was talking something about our kid. Yeah.
You don't even know what it is that I'm talking about. Like you don't even care.
You're just like, make it stop. Don't do that. Yeah.
All I did was she just started tearing up. She's like, you know what,
to talk to you about something. I'm just worried during futures.
He started doing that and when she did that, I just made this.
I just looked at me a little sad phase and then she looked up and saw me and
then you started fucking laughing. It was funny as you had tears in your eyes,
but you were laughing and then she, she kept trying to go back to crying again.
No, listen to me.
I'm just trying to stay and then I would make the sad face again. Guys,
you gotta do that to you woman, next time she gets no there.
Look if it's something fucking serious. It was so, you know, it wasn't,
yes it was. It was silly.
I thought it was trivial. Not exactly a c.
Not everyone is going to be as, you know.
I thought it was trivial cause it was coming out of your dumb head.
Zackly exactly. You don't even know when it was.
And I was concerned about you were concerned about the cops of the water.
Eight, eight. You laugh at like you baked.
So just the coast guard it,
the ship has sailed. No Pun intended. It's over.
Oh maybe Cuba.
Alright, fine. No, don't, don't,
don't give someone the pouty face when they're coming to you crying about an
emotional issue that they're feeling.
That's a terrible all right then tell me what you were concerned about.
I'll be a mature now. Good. What were you concerned about? Uh,
it was about, but
it's a good move because it keeps you happy. All right. That's the podcast.
That's the podcast. I know we have the creepy surveillance, the monitoring.
So you shot her with like a dart or something. She just face down.
She's out. That's like some discovery channel when you want to tag an animal.
Um, all right. That's the podcast for this Monday. A go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday. Thank you to everybody.
Came out to the shows this weekend, this weekend in St Petersburg, and uh,
I had a great time once again out there,
a cigar capital of the u s Nini.
It was fucking tremendous. It was tremendous. All right, I'll see you guys.